you
LASIK is a surgical procedure intended
to reduce a person's dependency on
glasses or contact lenses
the term lasik stands for laser-assisted
in situ keratomileusis and is a
procedure that permanently changes the
shape of the cornea which is the clear
covering over the front of the eye lasik
is an outpatient surgical procedure that
usually requires about 15 minutes per
eye before the procedure you will be
asked to lie on your back and remain
still topical eye drops will be used to
numb your eye and the area around the
eye will be washed and cleansed you may
also be given a sedative to help you
relax
your doctor will use an instrument
called a lid speculum to hold your
eyelid open and then place a ring on
your eye that creates suction on the
cornea you may feel pressure and
experience dimming of your vision at
this point in the surgery once the ring
is firmly in place your doctor will
attach a special device called a micro
carat ohm to the suction ring using the
blade on the micro carat ohm your doctor
will create a corneal flap by cutting
approximately the outermost 20% of your
cornea and lifting it carefully to one
side
after removing the suction ring in micro
karat ohm your doctor will use pulses
from a computer-controlled excimer laser
to reshape your cornea by vaporizing
tiny portions of its interior this part
of the procedure usually takes less than
60 seconds your doctor will then replace
the corneal flap in to its original
position and observe the eye for several
minutes to ensure bonding because the
cornea bonds so quickly healing is rapid
and the eye does not require stitches
after the procedure your doctor will
administer antibiotic drops and place a
shield over your eye to prevent you from
rubbing it or from putting pressure on
it while you sleep since you will not be
able to drive immediately following the
procedure you will need to make
arrangements for a ride home